Good morning John. We like to have a pretty
positive attitude here at Vlogbrothers, but once a year,
once a year I like to get furious. For not really
great reasons, but today
is that day this year. John, today, I'm going
to have seventeen rants in four minutes.
This. Whatever - I recognize that it is food;
I don't mind putting it on a sandwich
every once in a while, but Kraft?
Do not call this cheese!
That is not the texture, the smell, the taste,
or consistency of cheese! Calling it
American cheese
is an insult to both my country and my
second-favorite kind of food!
Speaking of food, 90% fat free
does not mean that it is
any percent fat free! It means it's
10% fat! It should just say that: "Ten percent fat".
Dear people who complain about the "chemicals"
that they're exposed to. EVERYTHING IS
CHEMICALS! Water,
your body, omega-3 fatty acids,
raspberries. Chemicals.
Continuing on this theme, stop saying
"all-natural" when you mean "healthy", because
there's lots of all-natural things that...
Like, I don't sit down
and, like, eat a tub of lard while marathoning Firefly!
But that would be "all-natural"!
What the crap is up with this kind of toilet paper?
Like I want to know who the diabolical
turd-face was who decided to promote
the discomfort of all mankind with this
harsh, non-perforated, flimsy... terribleness!
Speaking of public restrooms,
if you pee on the seat, any amount,
CLEAN IT UP YOU
TERRIBLE PERSON. IT'S YOUR PEE!
And someone is going to have to clean it up,
but if it's not you, they
will be cleaning up someone else's pee!
People who think that not knowing every
bit of a fandom's trivia makes you not a fan,
well, oh. I guess you were just born
with a deep and intense knowledge of the
backstory of Buffy the Vampire Slayer!
Were you not, at one time, an excited novice
just like the person you are
currently insulting?! Do you
really need to ruin that for them?!
Oh, okay, I see you were turning!
Oh, if only there had been some way for you
to signal your intent to do that!
Stop correcting people for saying "GIF" (jif)
or "GIF" (gif) wrong, they are both correct
pronunciations. By telling someone
they are doing it wrong, you are the only
person who is wrong!
Freaking ketchup, there's so much ketchup at the bottom.
And I know what you're saying –
you're saying, "Hank, why don't you just
get the squeezable kind?" Yeah, that's perfect
if I want to spray some
pink ketchup piss all over my fries!
[Tries to sneeze]
COME ON!!!
Manufactures of chair wheels everywhere.
I should have got this ready before.
I've got the chair on my lap.
Freaking knots!
Freaking... why are they always in knots?!
Can you please make it so that this doesn't fit
in this? Because this...
IS THE WORST THING!!! AHHHHHH!!!
If you're still using "gay" as an insult, it's not just
really insulting to gay people, it also
makes you sound really
immature and kind of stupid. So stop!
And finally, to all the people who are going to
complain about me complaining in this
video, because we all have it so good!
Yes. I recognize that I am a wealthy person,
in the wealthiest country, at the
wealthiest moment so far in human history!
But nonetheless, somehow, it still hurts when I stub my
toe, and I'm still annoyed
when the freaking checkout thing asks me for
the tenth time if I have scanned my club card!
[Machine]: Have you scanned your club card?
No. I haven't scanned my club card. You know
how I know? Because you're still asking
me, you passive aggressive
robot sack of ketchup pee. GAH!
Final note at the end of this video.
A lot of people have told me that it's good to get
out your anger every once in a while, but
I've read research that in fact,
the angrier you are, the more angry you
become. So this, actually, is a bad idea.
Don't do the thing I just did, because now my heart rate's all up, and I just want to enrage about everything.
[Panting]
I'll see you on Tuesday, John!